greetings you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 5th of [__]
january the joint is brought to you by
stamps.com
listen to me if i got a small business
so there's nothing more valuable than my
time
stamps.com makes it easy to mail and
ship right from your computer so you
could don't have to waste time and make
trips to the [__] post office now you
can save time and money with stamps.com
you can send letters packages for less
with discounted rates from usps ups and
much more my wife's been with stamps.com
for over 10 years now when it comes to
merch business stuff shipping stamps.com
is number one you just put the stuff in
a bag
lift up the little horn on the mailbox
and the mailman will pick it up since
1998 stamps.com has brought you the
service of the us postal service and ups
shipping right to your computer all you
need is a computer and a standard
printer no special supplies or equipment
within minutes you're up and running
print and postage for any letter package
anywhere once the mail is ready you
schedule a pickup that's it no traffic
no lines nobody breathing on your neck
and there's no risk so do me a favor
save time and money with stamps.com
and with my promo code joey j-o-e-y
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top at
the home page and type in joey that
stamps.com promo code joey never go to
the post office again when you get
stamps.com the joint is also brought to
you by
[Music]
d lion
whether you have an old injury anxiety
muscle lake cbd lion has something for
you go to cbdline.com and look at the
third party lab results read learn about
the advantages of cbd
cbn's making a big comeback well they're
not making a comeback they've been here
they're just growing and growing and
growing more people are aware of it but
cbd cbn cby
go to cbd line read all you can
and whatever you need whether it's the
cream whether it's the capsules whether
it's the tincture whether it's the cbd
lion tape the bath balls cbd lions got
you and they're coming out with a new
line
of cbd cigarettes hemp cigarettes i'm
waiting on all the information now go to
their website and let's get the party
started cbd lion preston joey joint and
get 10 percent off delivered right to
your [__] house and from the
heart of new jersey the joint is brought
to you by draftkings listen i told you
monday it's the final week of pro
football
but college football is heading into the
national championship and draftkings is
an unbelievable offer to finish out the
year because then you got the playoffs
and the super bowl new customers just
bet five hours on any football team to
win if they do you win 200 and free bets
so that's one down the season with a big
win if sportsbook isn't available in
your state yet no problems everybody can
play draftkings daily fantasy football
contest for huge cash prizes draftkings
is giving all new customers a free shot
at a million dollars in total prices
with their first deposit so it's that
easy draftkings is also
giving you
a free shot
at a million dollars with the fantasy
sports where i got confused there for a
second but it don't matter download the
draftking sports book now
use promo code joey j-o-e-y and let's
have a good time your best five dollars
on any football team
they win you win 203 bets if they're
victorious it's that easy you have a
good time listen they got so much stuff
on draftkings
from the social thing to the stats hub
you learn you have a great time just use
promo code joey this week at draftking
sportsbook you got to be 21 older new
jersey indiana
pennsylvania only new customers only
minimum 5 deposit and a one dollar wager
required
one per customer restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem i want you to take care
of it
call 1-800 gambler but if not head over
to draftkings sportsbook
download it and let's win some
[__] getus let's get this party
started on a wednesday [__] morning
here
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's the 5th of january sorry about
sunday's podcast i was rushing it
i was just excited to see you
[__] as you could tell the
studio's not [__] even done yet i
haven't even started this covert as uh
i'm getting headaches that's it i'm done
with everything
i've been going to the gym i'm doing all
the regular [__]
but i've been waking up with headaches
in the middle of the night so i gotta
call in to the doctor see what the [__]
is going on it's steve my wife looked it
up
it's the end of the covered [__] uh
whole thing but man
this headache holds you down but it's a
beautiful [__] day to be alive we're
here we're [__] queer
a lot of shit's been happening lately
man
and i'm adding it all like i did not see
it for a year i felt really guilty
about what i was going through whatever
the [__] it was you know not being able
to focus and
having no desire to do [__] you know it
was like a cross between like a
depression and anxiety whatever who know
who knows what it was i started
journaling
you know i started talking to my loved
ones a lot more and i got myself a
little back i'm a little bit better you
know but i'm looking around
in the world man it's [__] nuts
and it's crazier than ever you know i
somebody told me the other day on like
patreon that they're really worried
about their kids
world you know they're they're upset
because
they don't know what type of world
they're going to leave their kids and
then i'll tell you
i don't know i don't know it's not
looking [__] good you know it's not a
good [__] world when i make a betty
white joke three days after she's dead
and [__] facebook [__] bans me for
[__] i don't know i went to post
something this morning and i said first
off they sent me all i wrote
was uh betty white is dead and i don't
feel so good myself
it's a beautiful day whatever the [__] i
wrote and they wrote back that's broke
the compliance for guidelines of
violence and
so they said do you want to challenge it
and i go yeah i'll [__] challenge it
i didn't say nothing wrong i've been
saying the same [__] on there for 10
[__] years just a different person
and let me ask you guys when i say that
i'm not feeling good it's a joke
it's a joke for everybody like you know
betty white is dead and i don't feel so
good myself it all started with elvis is
dead and i don't feel so good myself so
every time somebody else dies you just
throw that name in as a reference so
please when i write that [__] don't say
get well because that's not what i'm
writing it's just a [__] stupid
[__] joke you know
but for facebook to [__] take that
down
like i woke up to that
tuesday morning and i was like dude what
the [__] is going on like this
i'm off for that
statement but that's the thing and i
wake up and rogan's not on twitter no
more he's on get a get you whatever the
[__] it is because
trump's people
listen it's a crazy [__] world
you know i know they ripped his videos
down i know sam's living and
you know he's living as a [__] hidden
man
you know everybody listen you could put
i had the understanding that you could
put whatever the [__] you want down on
twitter and facebook but you just
couldn't [__]
say something about covert on there you
know it doesn't go to golfing guidelines
we don't know what we're talking about
whatever that's fine it's like uh
twitter has become like a [__] bar on
the lower east side no politics and no
religion you can't you can't talk that
[__] on that that's a twit yeah that's
what twitter has become i mean you know
me i gotta be honest with you i'd love
to switch over together mike set me up
with a little account maybe i'll switch
over there before i get thrown off but
listen i'm to the point in my life when
you throw me off
i'm leaving
like i'm not [__] arguing with you no
more you know listen
it's a different world it's changing the
internet's [__] changing
it was crazy for a long [__] time we
had a good time but the party's over no
more no more guys blowing horses and
[__] you know i went into the deep web
about a week ago they told me to go [__]
myself in the deep web not even doing
nothing
any over there anymore
sure now i [__] start the podcast now
the guy could call me for a zoom that's
the way life turns out you know what i'm
saying
yeah who gives a [__] with here we're
queer it's wednesday morning i'm feeling
[__] good and then
you know we all saw what happened on uh
sunday i cracked a joke about it thank
god i didn't get uh punished for that
one you know antonio brown
pulled the bert [__] took his shirt
off at jet stadium let me tell you
something it was [__] cold that day
i was i was at jimmy's watching the
[__] game and we're watching antonio
brown and i was almost sent an uber for
that [__] i was like damn
antonio brown's in jersey let's get this
[__] over and experiment with
him
but after watching that you know they
reminded me of guys i don't know if you
guys remember when martin lawrence
was found on ventura boulevard with a
gun with no shirt on yelling maybe 20
years ago
you know he was under stress and [__]
like that i love martin lawrence so you
can't say nothing bad to me about that
dude
but it's just really weird that you're
seeing these people
going [__] nuts you know and i got to
be honest with you man
the other day my friend called me they
can't find pests
and i got to be [__] strictly
honestly i got a call from a buddy of
mine saying that um
you know you couldn't find the test that
he went to a supermarket in jersey and
they wanted forty dollars
for a test and i go you know
that's what the world is coming to now
you know i hung up the phone with him
and i was like
how much
[__] can americans keep [__] taking
how much [__] can we keep taking
you know you wake up i make a betty
white joke they throw me off a [__]
facebook
i go visit my family at the airport i'm
there two hours and they cancel my
flight and i gotta sit there all [__]
day i can't get covert test you know uh
you can't get everything you want for
[__] christmas there's nothing on the
[__] shelves we're getting horrible
information on it daily we don't even
know we get a vaccine we get covert you
got a booster you get covered who the
[__] knows anymore america is [__]
suffering like we're getting beat up on
a daily listen i've been beat up all my
[__] life so i'm used to it i don't
give a [__] i just got out of the comedy
world where you get beat up every
[__] day for everything you think
about
but as a human being i'm looking around
me and i'm like what
when does this end
you know i woke up monday morning and
it was
40 degrees
it was cloudy it was dark all of a
sudden we got a text no school
no school because there's a snow day on
monday you know here might
do you have any idea what this house
went through during coven i mean listen
it was a great holiday you know i know
people have it worse some people were in
the [__] hospital for christmas so
i'm not crying but for a week nobody
would play with her
nobody would play with her
you know we were marked like the [__]
bastards on the block you know
she could play outside with the
neighbors because they were going
through some coveting [__] but
she didn't get to you know we did
christmas here and it was it was great
and
but she didn't see her friends over the
[__] holidays it was cold on these
[__] streets that's number one
number two you know i had covert and i
couldn't
drop it i wasn't gonna keep it a secret
you know and let my daughter go out
there and spread that [__] that's the
biggest fear i have today i was supposed
to go to
or yesterday i was supposed to go to a
place
and work out with a friend of mine he
has a guest pass he goes i really want
you to do this workout and i go you know
what man
i'm feeling a little [__] off like
i'm not 100 i want to double check
god like even mike you know me and mike
spoke about him coming on sunday last
week and and we were like nah because
he's got kids you know so the last thing
i want to do
is [__] spread some so i canceled
that i don't want to go in there just in
case now listen i know i'm not
contagious it's just like the fifth day
i think the day after i got the
the uh little cornmeal whatever the [__]
it is that day i saw the nurse do
something with a mask
and i said
why are you taking it off she goes
listen you're not really contagious
today like after five days you know
really contagious or whatever she said
so my daughter didn't get it my wife
didn't get it mike hasn't gotten it yet
so uh we don't know what the [__] to
expect
but
i don't know i i see
people getting beat up and we're just
taking it
like we're just taking it we're not
pulling turning around and yelling we're
not doing nothing like we just take it
like we just either turn the tv off or
[__] hang up the phone or shut the
computer down but every day
this is worrying on us so when you see
antonio brown do something like that
listen i was laughing my [__] ass off
okay i'm the first guy that was laughing
i'm not gonna sit here
and tell you that you know but after
reviewing that
and seeing what my man tom brady said
the baddest white man that ever lived he
even trumps jesus after sunday
uh
yeah tom brady's on a league of his own
but even when he came out
i looked into that i'm like yeah
people are going through wild [__] look
what's going on at airports and [__]
people are just pounding each other
people are pounding each other and you
know what man i'm i'm the bigger the man
the bigger the mistake i was wrong about
a lot of things during this time
you know i didn't
you know i look at these guys bashing
uh everybody's getting bashed
whether if you do a vaccine if you don't
do a vaccine
if you [__] you know everybody's getting
bashed for something if you if you do a
show
i saw neil young as mad at performance
because they're doing
dead touring i had the same issues
myself but you know what i started
thinking about it and wait a second guy
these people are our only entertainment
these people are the only [__] break
that we get right now
that's it these when we go to a concert
or you go to a movie like last week
[__] spider-man made 50 billion
[__] dollars
nobody gave a [__] about coven you know
everybody wanted to go see spider-man
let me tell you something
it's not that people wanted to go see
spider-man
is that they need entertainment
they need something you know what the
drugs ain't working no more they've been
doing drugs for two [__] years
i mean i talked to my ex drug dealer
about a month ago the cocaine has gone
off the roof
and then now people are running out of
money so they're going from coke
to that [__] you small speed
the the speed the met whatever crank i
don't [__] know
so that that and that's never a good
[__] choice right there in your
career
once you do cranky you just got a couple
[__] days left after that so
i see the drug use i see
the pain on people's faces you know i'm
watching these
you know i go on instagram and
to check and look you know
and guys it don't look good
i see a lot of people faking the funk
and that's fine but that catches up with
you you know i tried to fake the funk
for years it catches [__] up with you
man
you can't keep smiling every [__] day
like nothing nothing's dumping on you
we're getting dumped on a [__] daily
basis i don't know if this is planned
i don't know if this is a conspiracy i
don't give a [__] what it is but i know
that
as americans right now man
look what happened last week so
you [__] live all year you know
everybody's jumping up and down you went
to see guns and roses you went
to atlantic city you went here you went
there you went to baseball games
and the thing that you want to do the
most
spend time with your family over the
holidays now became a [__] hurdle now
don't get me wrong guys
in 1983 i thought i was cute and i
decided to take a plane from
colorado or something to whatever sure
enough we got 12 inches of snow the day
i wanted to fly i think it was
thanksgiving 83. i made a when i was
living in snowmass that was the first
time i ever went home i was excited as
[__] and let me tell you something
so i got in the plane wednesday i didn't
get home with all the delays and [__] i
didn't get back to jersey till thursday
and then i left like sunday and i didn't
get back to colorado to [__] monday
because yeah i landed in denver but i
had to get to aspen and that flight
always got [__] canceled if you had
the eight o'clock flight and you had to
actually stay on the [__] airport and
[__] sleep but it was different back
then isn't the the bar stayed open i'd
put my cocaine in the locker
[__] i swear to god they had those
lockers like can get shorty where he hit
the coke and get shorty and [__] i would
hide my coke in there go to a bar have
three drinks go back one night i dropped
a hundred and quarters because i kept
going back and forth opening up the
[__] coke at two dollars a [__]
shot to open up the locker
so
it's the truth man
i [__] went off one night i remember
one night i got caught at that i used to
get caught at
denver airport all the time
i got caught there all the [__] time
and i got to be honest with you i look
forward to it
because the bars were open
chicks were there you could talk to i
remember one time i met like a music
mogul you think i'm [__] canyon i
started giving this guy coke and [__] we
started talking he's talking about the
bands i'm not [__] kidding he was
they had like the beastie boys he had
some big ass bands he had pictures with
the beastie boys he showed me the
contracts you know if he was going to
california or something like that we
both got delayed in denver i was going
to aspen he was a connecting flight we
talked for hours i might call them the
next day he's like
no it wasn't no rick rubin it was some
white dude that was powerful but the
next day i'm like hey
remember me and he's like get the [__]
out of here i wasn't even into [__]
comedy then or anything this is 83. i
just met him at the airport and i got
him all coked up until like the [__]
morning and
he gave me his number and i'm like [__]
i'm in the music industry now jack i'm
gonna join a band i'm gonna play the
ukulele i call this [__] he's
like what
i go nah listen man i wanted to [__]
uh talk to you about the music and he
goes get the [__] out he just hung up on
me i knew nothing no what happened was
this
i had a [__] idea
i was at a hotel one day and like 80
something hanging out and some big black
dude was there we were talking he was
telling me he was i swear to god i had
this conversation with him guys he was
telling me he produced rap music and all
this [__] and i remember looking them in
the face
and going dog we need a white rapper
and we talked about at this hotel for
like an hour a white rapper white rap i
never saw him again then two months
later him and then popped out and i look
like a [__] [__] you know all the
beastie boys popped out because yeah
this is 82 i don't even the beastie boys
came out like 85 or something like that
so
but you know the more i look around man
i'm like
something's gotta [__] break i'm very
excited
i'm down here in south jersey surrounded
by trees bears
and italian people from staten island
i'm good but i don't even try to go up
[__] north i mean it's just i gotta
go up there tomorrow for a [__] week
and guys it's the last thing i wanna
[__] do
it's the last thing i wanna [__] do
i just watched somebody talking about
wakes
oh steve sharipa was talking to david
chase
about wakes that he [__] hated wakes
he hated all the waste and the sopranos
blah blah blah blah blah blah that's the
only thing i agree with the sopranos
when you move to jersey you go to a lot
of [__] wakes they're huge here
people love their wakes
they love them me i i think they're the
creepiest [__] things in the world
and i'll be honest with you after my
mother died and i know you heard that
little underground burp
it was tremendous my wife made a
i went to the gym today and i'm [__]
my wife had leftover uh pot roast with
short ribs in it for flavor god damn
i ate the last two little short ribs i'm
ready to go
when we first busted it out
i didn't find any today because mike was
coming his family i didn't want to blow
him out of the water but she put a bunch
of garlic in there and they didn't blow
up
they just like halfway like it's halfway
like i don't know
so she gave them to me
the first day she made it last night
she's like oh look at my thing i got so
much garlic oh is this what this is what
happened to it just blew up
let me tell you something i hate every
[__] garlic clove last night we were
watching guy fieri's [__]
dinos dives or something
i got excited about something i blew a
fart
my daughter even went like what the [__]
is that she didn't say what the [__] is
that smell she goes dad it smells really
bad down here what was that
that's a tremendous garlic fart
i mean it was horrible i took two garlic
farts and after that i took a dump
and i was done with the garlic and i'm
like i'm not gonna eat any more garlic
because mike is coming tomorrow i
haven't been farting in the podcast
because i
i don't know i think my [__] just
lovely
and he just wanted to fart for [__]
league you know that was it
poorly he's still recovering from his
[__] vacation in hell that's what i
said like even somebody like lee
sweetheart of a guy
you know never wants to be nobody
he goes to mexico to take his girlfriend
on a [__] trip
and it sucks dick like i don't know what
he paid for the vacation but i know it
wasn't cheap
so now you go he's back he was cracked i
mean he called me immediately when he
got back he was a little bit more
cracked than he was on the podcast he
was a little warped on the podcast
remember he was like the podcast
straight and he's like i don't know
what's going on but
he's the sweetheart of a guy but even
somebody like him it's like him it looks
like mike
mike is a working guy
you know he takes his wife out it's a
big [__] deal
for him to go to mexico it's a big
[__] deal they saved a year they put
away [__] they had to get baby care and
then you go to [__] mexico the food
tastes like [__] mexican feet it
smells down there he was telling me all
this [__] that was wrong with it i mean
how much can americans take
last year they sat down for [__] uh
you know you sat down for [__] 18
months you were in the [__] house
dreaming of going on a [__] vacation
first off you look at the [__] prices
i don't know if you check prices
what are they doing to americans
what the [__] are they doing to
americans in new york when i got to new
jersey gas
was 204 pushing
pushing that means if i went on the nine
and took a mine a mild ride down
i would see a gallon for 195. it's some
[__] hindu gas station the gas is cut
like [__] bad cocaine they cut it
with fentanyl and [__] god knows what
they're putting in there
but it was still dom 95 i'll tell you
what we're going to hit 400 for florida
we're going to hit four hours before the
year's over
what does that do to people's [__]
you know i mean what does that do all
these little we're just getting beat up
as americans right now and listen i'm
not complaining like i said i've been
beat up all my life but when does it
[__] end
we should catch a little break what do
you think i was the only guy that had a
i can't say i had a shitty holiday but
you think i was the only guy that was
stuck at home for the holidays with
covert i know 10 other [__] people
that breaks you a little bit didn't
break me because what would i give a
[__] at this point in the game i've
already jumped up and down for
christmases for [__] goddamn years
but it it affected a lot of [__]
people
you know now what about you live in
jersey any other place you wake up on
monday they close your school remote you
know what it's like to have your [__]
kid at home for three weeks
listen i love mercy i love my daughter i
love kids in the neighborhood
but kids need to [__] go out
kids need to socialize kids that need to
play sports kids need to do so many more
things than we do if not i mean listen
if it's between her and i she eats and i
don't i got 50 pounds of [__] fat on
me i could live for [__] ever but
that's
the way i go i want her to have a
[__] good life i'll miss i'd rather
[__] live in a closet and have her
have a great bedroom and all that [__]
but i think these kids are feeling again
remote for [__] three weeks four
weeks you know thank god our school's
gonna stay open and she gets in to
socialize and you know what if a kid
gets [__] covered they're not pushing
the [__] listen if
if kids were dying from coven
i wouldn't have my daughter out there
i wouldn't have my [__] daughter out
there banging out every goddamn day
okay i would have her at home but guess
what kids aren't dying from [__] cold
i know three kids right now that have
kobe they have a slight [__] headache
and little [__] sniffles they could
have gone back to school but they took
city tests on saturday and friday and
it's registered with the city so now the
school's taking them off of ten [__]
days so
you know it it doesn't [__] we don't
we're not winning in this and yes it's a
bad pandemic
i don't know how many people [__]
dying anymore i don't listen i don't
believe nothing
and i love i love america we always have
like uh you know like a yeah but listen
covert yeah but nobody's in the hospital
nobody's dying you know we always have a
[__] excuse
you know what i don't know what the
[__] going on
but i know that right now we just need
to be pushing
we need to stick to our [__] like i woke
up a little
who bots tuesday morning and i gotta be
honest with you i'm not in my you know
elvis is dead and i don't feel so good
myself today
i'm a little shaken i don't know about
my future what the [__] wanna do
i don't know about my daughter's future
all i know is that i have to get up
every morning
give them love you know crack a few
[__] jokes here and there
be here for my daughter be here for my
wife and just stick close to the [__]
house and that's what i've been doing i
don't want to do dick anymore i'm to
that age now where i enjoy being close
to the house i got tons of buddies close
by i got tons of businesses that i
frequent and i have a great time at you
know i don't need to go to new york city
but what if i had to
what if i had to [__] work i had to
take a bus every day
and walk in the city and you know
because they're stabbing [__]
over there on a daily basis i don't give
a [__] what they're telling you see this
is what happens i'm gonna talk to you
guys about what happens
when you live in california
and i get home at six so whatever
[__] time i get home and i put the tv
on i watch the news how many times i've
called mike
or mercy's godfather james or one of my
friends and said hey this is really
going on you're saying they're like what
are you talking about
we don't even know what you're talking
about well i'm just sitting here
watching the news and it's telling me
that i don't know
people [__] get hit with head with
chairs in new york city
they'll tell you now that's not
happening and then you move on
and i would get calls from people in
jersey or new york city or boston when i
lived in california telling me the same
hey you okay
why what happened all right this
happened in l.a you you know how the
fires are you packed up did your house
blow the f no
but we're told the wrong information on
both [__] coasts they they show you
what they want to see
i don't even know where i was going with
this but the point i'm trying to make
here is that you wake up in the morning
with the best intentions that's what i
do i don't know what the day's going to
take me anymore i don't have a [__]
day job i don't have a comedy job
anymore i don't need to go to a [__]
audition there's no more [__]
auditions where you used to go down and
talk to the studio heads they don't want
you in there so my life has been thrown
for a [__]
loop also i enjoyed auditions when
you're a comic and you're going to
audition that's your whole day i'm
trying to look to see i lost my
insurance through sag this year uncle
joey's got no insurance near the sharon
stone i don't feel too [__] bad of
sharing sharon stone missed [__]
insurance this year with sag a bunch of
people don't have sag insurance you only
want to know what i have to pay for a
family plan
for sag insurance you guys want to know
why i'm getting into the weed business
because i got to pay for [__]
insurance insurance is [__] steep but
all that aside when i joined the screen
actors guild
in 1997 i remember how to go to like you
have to go like a [__] uh what do you
call those things where you go and they
tell you itinerary uh i don't know you
have to once you join the union they
have like these things to welcome you in
and they tell you about all the benefits
associated with sag i was told this to
me guys i was told
that if i had 45 years old
and i was always level two because they
whatever the [__] you call you uh after
you're in the union ten years they call
it something i forget right now too many
years of smoking dope
yeah like you get you get you earned
that so after 10 years or four for
tenure after 10 years or 45 years old
you get level two for the rest of your
life what's level two
level one is great insurance
no level two is great insurance except
you get vision
mental health
uh two chiropractors a month and
something else like once a month or
something like that that's level one
insurance but level two insurance ain't
bad i got surgeries on level two
insurance i [__] got glasses oh i
didn't get glass on level two insurance
i got something else my hearing aids on
level two insurance i got level two
insurance isn't bad
sorry about that i gotta take a little
[__] paper break
i gotta keep the [__] lungs healthy
you know what i'm saying you gotta keep
moving somebody asked me a day how did
you use your
reefer in your therapy for covert
are you [__] [__]
i didn't use what do you think i go i
went to webmd
and said how the [__] can i get reefer
into my therapy i just didn't smoke and
i smoked at night when i needed i was a
little scared of smoking
but i got to be honest with you i was
fine it helped listen i've always been
into smoking when i got a flu or
something like that you know why
you ever take a hit off a [__] good
joint
and you start coughing and [__] and
start drooling and [__] goes everywhere
that's actually pretty good for your
[__] lungs
did you know that that when you cough
like that it's actually good for your
[__] lungs i did not know that i'm
not saying if you smoke 29 000 marlboro
reds every day you [__] you know no
i'm talking about if you cough it's good
for you it's good for you
so that's what i used it as i it wasn't
therapeutic i smoked to get high to
watch tv at night to fall asleep
because i'm to the point in my life now
where
since i'm not a [__] gavon anymore
smoking 24 7
i could smell in fact i'm going to be as
honest as i can with you i don't even
know when the last time i smoked the
joint was i've been hitting that bubbler
for the last three weeks when you have
great weed
if you got laughing gas or any of that
product from ice cream shop or anything
like that and you smoke you take three
hits off that bubbler i mean listen
three hits could kill the regular human
i'm not lying to you that
that thing hits like a [__] savage
but if you take three hits of that
i'm pretty [__] good for the rest of
the night i swear to god
i gotta go upstairs and get a bag of
something at some point which is always
a great [__] sign you know uh doritos
which i'll do once every two weeks or
something like that i try to drink like
a protein
shake or a [__] milkshake that's my
speedo milkshake a [__] apple a
couple apples i've been into apples
again i bought a bunch of fruit my wife
would go honey buy a bunch of fruit
when i got the covert i go just you know
get some nice little fruit
dog i had to throw it all away the only
thing that was good were the [__]
blueberries
that's it everything
nothing tastes like everything and
listen i didn't lose my taste with
covert
but like everything was raw like not raw
but it was like i had melon
not that good
i had a watermelon not that good
i got some strawberries didn't even
[__] taste like strawberries the
blueberries are really [__] good and
they're good antioxidants when all that
[__] and the apples are good but all the
other [__]
what else did i got i got like a melon a
watermelon
and there was something else i didn't
get a mango i couldn't find a [__]
mango
and it's so funny how living in jersey
is completely different from california
when you live in california everybody
gives you tamales for christmas
i used to give away tamales between
silent bob
a couple other mexican dudes they would
drop off ten rick ramos they would drop
off ten pork [__] tamales and then
you bumped into a lady selling them
there's always a woman selling them i
couldn't get a [__] tamale in new
jersey i got coquito like a [__]
you ever drink coquito i got a bottle
here coquito is a is a puerto rican
coconut with rum type drink a little uh
it's like puerto rican eggnog that's
what coquito is it's puerto rican eggnog
i bought two bottles to support this uh
blue uh my friend's father is a cop and
he sells them for
police officers so i bought two bottles
the first night i had covered i couldn't
fall asleep i was like [__] i read
somewhere that if you take uh
i didn't know i had covert at that point
i can't lie to you [__] i had
no idea covered at that point but
somebody i read somewhere if you take
like a milky protein
and uh the [__] i take to sleep the kids
what do you give your kids to sleep when
when they're sneezing and [__]
no the other [__] that puts him the [__]
out for hours
benadryl oh
three or four benadryls just sleep like
a [__] baby too bad i outgrew it now
i got two upstairs i might drop this
afternoon and take a quick little nappy
noodle but
i took uh it said a milky protein
and some benadryl and i'm like i got
benadryl
and i got like milk i could put protein
powder in it but wait a second i got
coquito so i went upstairs i opened that
bottle of [__] coquito now my buddy
made me a bottle that was no bueno i
love him to death eddie
lisa great people but
that [__] had so much rum in it
i drank a little bit of it and i got
[__] up so i couldn't do that one i
had to be a mild mild-mannered one i
went upstairs i opened up one of those
blue bottles of coquito
i brought it down here i took my [__]
whatever the [__] he called him
benadryl
dog i was taking little sips of that
coquito i ended up drinking the whole
[__] bottle i looked at the bottom
like oh
i'm gonna have to do 29 000 sit-ups
tomorrow because this puts a lot of
weight on you between the alcohol
the [__] the rum
the cream there's heavy cream in there
coconut milk god knows what else is in
there puerto rican toenails i don't know
what the [__] was in there i drank that
[__] and i could i could look
years old
i was not drunk i was just [__]
constipated
i don't know what the rum did to me i
don't know if it i
don't work on i'm cuban rum don't do
[__] i got so much room in my veins from
my grandparents this [__] it doesn't
even affect me
but i drank that bottle one night
[__] delicious but the next day dog i
felt like barfing all [__] day i
didn't even touch the eggnog like my
wife bought american eggnog and i would
look at it every day like i can't wait
that [__] eggnog maybe throw a little
something in there i don't know what to
throw in there i like it just straight
with a glass with ice cubes oh delicious
i didn't even drink the [__] eggnog
because i drank so much [__] coquito
i felt [__]
guilty from drinking an eggnog so i was
like i gotta give the [__] coquito a
break
but man
it's january [__] fifth
and i feel uh
i don't feel like my feet are on the
ground
like it's just been such a wild [__]
week so far like
i went to cvs it looks like mad max in
there
there's nothing on the [__] shelves
you know
i'm running behind on stuff i ordered
some albums i just got a [__] note
two days ago the albums are running ten
days late
i don't know where the [__] they are
stuck i got some pretty cool albums on
ebay i just wanted to take a chance to
see what was out there not on ebay i
ordered some albums on uh
one of the sites on there somebody sent
me a site with like heavy metal albums
and [__]
like i got like judas priest uh
the one that came out in 80
british steel that's a hard one to find
in good shape i think i got one there
but this one was the original one or
whatever so i paid a little extra doe
for it just to
sprucing up the [__] uh
uh album of the week just to get that
going a little bit more because my two
album shops closed i'm waiting for this
artist to have a
he has a [__] viewing every january
jimmy took me last year that's where i
got the
guns and roses and i think i got
something else no i got the led zeppelin
big one from the garden in 77.
and i got something else jimmy ended up
getting it was right after van halen
died jimmy got a tremendous
heady van halen with him drinking
champagne [__] tremendous we went
there we spent two or three hours i
remember was in the middle of covert i
had to wear my mask i was taking i just
found the pictures the other day the the
decade that rocked he took
yeah yeah yeah he took the pictures from
humphug
and all that [__] you know from uh that
one club in the city
great
just [__] great so i'm waiting for
him
to see if they do that music uh
screening this year
what was his name and here's the funny
thing about that guy the guy that
this photographer
like i've had the pleasure of
interviewing photographers the last
couple years and stuff they're
interesting [__] very
interesting you know they tell you this
like this guy here i forget what his
name is
he was in i just saw that one night i
was watching the
the uh
rick james documentary
he spent three weeks with rick james and
had to take pictures of him and [__]
that's why i want to see him because i
want to ask him about rick james the
last time i saw this guy
the photographer was we did uh remember
i did ozzy's boneyard for new year's eve
last year he was on deck after me
but the thing about photographers man
they got balls of steel whether it's the
guy had on i can't remember what his
name on before i left
l.a great guy his wife was my coach
he was like guns n roses guitarist he
was also
he had that video we put on this was the
weirdest podcast we did because
he did the podcast
and on the way out he goes hey put that
video on and we put a video on it was
him with jimmy page and harold smith and
we're like
why don't you tell us this during the
podcast yeah and he goes well i never
really thought of it like all right so
he went home and i called him i said
listen the podcast didn't work come back
tomorrow
and do it again and this time open up
with that [__] video
so people know that you're a [__]
savage you know what he told this story
but this guy had a tremendous story
about being 15
and sticking the cameras and his buying
oversized jeans
and sticking the cameras and his jeans
and
the extra little black containers of
film they used to be these little black
containers when we were kids like if you
bought a bag of weed you got an envelope
but if you were really cool you got in
one of those [__] film containers i
know a lot of you young guys don't know
what i'm talking about but some of the
old goats like me you know what the [__]
i'm talking about they would if you went
to the city to buy weed in those days
they'd give you a yellow manila envelope
a small one and it had a mark of where
the weed was going to be filtered but if
you got a good dealer he'd fill it up a
little [__] more for you and you
wrapped it up and that was the end of
that if you were really cool you sold
weed and little film canisters oh my god
i still remember bringing the film
canisters home people like where'd you
get those you like the cool kid on the
block for like an hour until they
realize you're with dunce
ross
rob alfred ross
what's his name ross rose
ross
no no no no that's one of the good guys
yeah this guy was on
he did the
he took all these pictures
sorry if i'm turning [__] up i got a
little bit of a migraine headache i had
to take a couple town laws and relax
before mike came here today
but listen headaches
[__] uh toe jam
fungi toe whatever it is
800 milligrams of thc 2 000 milligrams
of thc i try to always show up man i got
a [__] headache
you know we were gonna do a zoom today
but i figured
mark weiss is his name mark weiss
is a [__] interesting guy it was one
of the best days i had i had just gotten
here and jimmy's like you want to go to
this rock thing the guy's got you know
pictures i didn't know what to expect i
thought he's gonna have pictures of
local bands i opened the door he's got a
picture of [__] you know motley crew
in there when they're like [__] 10. i
was like where the [__] did you get this
and he's he just started unloading on me
and you know
it's so weird how
you know musicians want to be
comedians
comedians want to be musicians you know
last night i was watching uh two nights
ago i was watching monday night football
and snoop dogg was on with the two
brothers with the the quarterback peyton
brothers you know i don't know if you
watch monday night football but you can
watch a regular with the regular [__]
announcers or you can watch it with the
peyton brothers i always watch with the
peyton brothers when i watch it because
they always have interesting [__]
people on monday night they had on homie
from [__] green bay that's the best
podcast i had in a long time that homie
from green bay
snoop dogg and roger goodell and then i
after that i got bored i
you know i could just watch monday night
football [__] so long
but it was great to watch listen man a
couple weeks ago i went on a [__]
tear on twitter
you know i was watching pittsburgh one
night i'm just a dog i'm a i'm a fan of
everybody you want me to tell you i'm a
fan of the giants or whatever nah i like
all the [__] teams i like them all
for a different reason pittsburgh has
been in my blood
since you know i was a kid look what i
got on today [__] clemente i love
anything [__] pittsburgh jimmy
florentine gave me this for christmas
size 3x it's nice it's not that warm but
it was his anniversary on uh
it was his death anniversary on uh
saturday maybe yeah
new year's day is when roberto clemente
was [__] dead or when they found him
dead i had no [__] idea but
that's the day i found out he was dead
he died on the way to managua nicaragua
bringing supplies for the
dudes from earthquakes so i was always
loved pittsburgh whether it was football
basketball i don't like the penguins
but i like the pirates also so i'm
watching pittsburgh i don't know who the
[__] they were playing
and they just look like [__] they and
ben roethlisberger whatever his [__]
name is listen i was a fan of his for a
while but then i went to pittsburgh and
people were telling me the horror
stories about him and [__]
and i was like i can't i can't watch
this guy no more but i didn't watch
football for a long time so he didn't
[__] matter to me and i started
[__] watching football two years ago
i'm like what is up with his head like
his head looks like my old cat if you
don't [__]
cut a cat's dick off testosterone keeps
growing in him and his head gets really
[__] big have you ever had a male cat
and they're not fixed their [__] head
is huge that's what happened to ben
rothenberger i don't know what the [__]
happened to that [__] but i was
watching them and it was one of the
worst
it was thanksgiving weekend
and there was three [__] bloods
that's what it was and one blowout was
justifiable
but the other one pittsburgh was not
justifiable i grew up watching jack
lambert and jack hamm and all these
[__] savages
and and you know franco harris and
[__]
you know the really good quarterback
that's on nfl today i grew up watching
these [__] guys and i'm watching this
this wasn't even a close to [__]
pittsburgh football and after the game i
was so upset i just took it to [__]
twitter i'm like what the [__] is going
on here i was and people were pissed at
me pittsburgh people understood where i
was coming from because i explained
myself
i wasn't bashing them this was not the
pittsburgh i was used to [__]
watching all those years
so i went off and then he was on monday
night football this week and i watched
him and i felt guilty about what i said
you know
his last game was monday at home thank
god they're shipping that big headed
[__] out hopefully they'll bring in
aaron rodgers or my man from seattle and
pittsburgh will be back in their [__]
glory days like i remember him and [__]
not this nonsense i'm watching on tv now
i've been watching sports lately guys so
i'm getting emotional about this [__]
but
it doesn't really matter i had a good
time monday night
and like i said this is the first week
of the year
people are still scattered
i'm [__] scattered uh
we're gonna do the studio this week
hopefully i got a couple days now
my mind is everywhere you know there's
so many things i want to say and do and
there's so many ideas i have with this
podcast but i don't know where to
[__] start
but this week i feel a lot better over
the off week i'm gonna move some [__]
around in here
and uh we're gonna get this thing tip
top magoo if not i'll tell you what the
other option i had guys i'm just gonna
go dark
i've been thinking about it just going
dark
no more youtube videos
just audio that's it it's easier on me
i could just talk i don't have to look
in the camera and feel guilty anymore
i don't have to worry about my eyelashes
or my eyebrows i don't have to worry
about my nose hair i don't have to worry
about what's behind me and i can just
talk and tell you [__] what's
in my heart and do that for 45 minutes
and move on i do not [__] know we're
running all [__] scenarios here mike
came up today we're going to install
some speakers
so the sound quality is better that
[__]
thing that ralphie gave me is good for
like a little room
not if you want to [__] smoke dope
and listen to music it just doesn't cut
it i want to start hooking uh
you know earphones and [__] like that
i'm getting all these new albums so
i want to change this around guys listen
sometimes you're [__] stale and i ran
into covid
and just i've had bad luck this year
when it comes to [__] uh
you know all this [__] i mean in la i
put the feelers out i could find the
garage
in [__] 10 days like i did with that
office it just took a little while i put
feelers out [__] three months i think
i got like [__] five calls and
everything has been you know 22 30
[__] miles away
so the podcast right now the joint i'm
just being a little confused
the covert didn't help the holiday
didn't help me being down for a few
weeks didn't help
but we're gonna get this shape [__]
place up
tip top magoofy
i wish i could smoke some reefer back
here i'm really missing
smoking with you [__] but my
daughter will be here and i can't have
this your dad was in the backyard
[Music]
i just spoke to my wife my wife goes
we're having lunch somewhere we won't be
home for a while i was doing some work
around the [__] house
i went in the backyard in the afternoon
with my [__] uh
it's really tough to smoke with that
thing outside too
i don't know if you guys understand it's
i mean i love freeze pipe and their
products i love their bungs
but i gotta be honest with you if i take
that big bung
and smoking in front of my house
the cops will be here in 10 minutes
anybody who sees that bong
thinks it's like a [__] bomb
you know i've showed it to people when
they come over when you have to build it
even the little one
even the little bung is [__]
dangerous
so
i've had those like they're like
showroom models i don't want to smoke
out of them i use them for the podcast
take pictures of them the bubbler i
[__] use and people got mad at me
like
the [__] who gives a [__] i when i
took the picture before i had two
bubbles i gave one to mike i kept the
other one and i didn't smoke out of it
because i had smoking out of the other
one so when i put the picture of the
clean one up people were like what the
[__]
listen you're not gonna man that's how i
know the world's in bad shape
the internet responses like the comments
used to be bad 10 years ago
now they're all over the place
people are still accusing me of killing
jesus
yeah
it's it's a [__] nightmare so
we keep [__] trying here but besides
that
i'm swinging [__]
you know like i was telling mike i don't
know about stand-up i don't know if my
agents are gonna call me and put me in a
[__] movie
nobody knows what's going on right now
the numbers are high
all i know is i come here on mondays and
wednesdays
and [__] to you guys and hopefully
we'll make sense out of all this [__]
i'm not making sense on all this [__]
i'm just as confused as you are we've
been [__] they've been throwing
information at us at such a high rate of
speed the last two years
that we all need a [__] breather you
know
if it was up to me i'd [__] disappear
but i love you [__] and i can't
leave you in a wretch like this the
world is in a bad place and you
[__] need uncle joey and
believe it or not uncle joey needs you
[__] suckers too
you know i'm working hard i'm trying to
put the pieces together with patreon and
everything i answer my messages i make
my videos let me tell you some of the
patreon app
if i could light that [__] thing on
fire i would
every [__] you know how many nights i
would sit in this table spend an hour
[__] getting the music lined up
getting it all ready for why did i stop
doing music on patreon for the intros
it's an hour
and then you go to [__] put the thing
down and you're like
that's not the song i played
it's playing like white lines i'm
putting up sabbath bloody sabbath and
white lines is coming up so i gotta call
my niece she's gonna clean out the
[__] hole put it in there again then
you got another [__] thing
that's from july 18th so i just said
[__] i can't deal with this [__] no more
because everything's kicking my [__]
ass i said enough you know i would i i
love music i love music to motivate in
the morning nothing motivates as soon as
listen as soon as i wake up in the
morning i don't and i pee i get up i
[__] i got my dick in my hand i'm
paying
i'm thinking about what i got to do that
day
but i'm also thinking about what song am
i going to put on to make me want to
stab three [__] today
and by the time i [__] wash my hands
from the first p
the song is already in my [__] head
this morning it was uh
msg on and on i love that [__] jam
and this
michael jordan might michael jordan
michael shang the group
the second album 19
i think it came out maybe
81 maybe it came out [__] the one
side
michael shang this torture in that
[__] guitar i listen to that in the
morning and make me want to stab
somebody so when i wake up in the
morning i would get those i'd bring my
[__] little computer back here i'd
get it all keyed up the [__] speaker
and all of a sudden an hour of work and
i can't download it on [__]
patreon i've had enough i've had enough
so now i just go on there and yell in
the morning get up stab a [__]
stab your mother i don't know who the
[__] knows i was reading where that guy
stabbed his mother and his father on
christmas day in long island because of
child custody and [__]
and i'm like
it's getting [__] weird
by the day
christmas day you're going to stab your
mother and your father
it's a new [__] world out there i'm
just coming on here on mondays and
wednesdays just to give you a little
levity just to show you i'm [__] up
too but i'm halfway there
so please bear with me
next week's shows will be a lot better
we'll have the [__] zoom i mean zoom
is it guys that's it
that's it unless
they come up with zoom plus
or something we need something [__]
new we've been zooming for two [__]
years everybody's [__] zooming you
know i watched that thing monday night
they're [__] zooming and you say when
is this [__] zoom gonna end then the
numbers go up again and we're right back
where the [__] we started from so
even the podcast unless you're rogan and
you can [__] blood test the guy when
he gets there and [__] like that
i can't afford that [__] machine i
looked into it i can't even afford 10
tests they want 40 a [__] test now i
got them on sale for 18. now they want
40 dollars a [__] time so
i don't know what's going on i'm just
trying to do my best
to keep you [__] insane me sane and
my house saying i love you [__]
with all my heart i'll be back monday
tip top magoo
the tenth
and we'll talk some [__] then this is
the first week
let's just [__] write this off
say hello to each other we checked in
with each other and you [__]
know i love you have a great week man
we got some great [__] games this
weekend we got some great college
basketball great cup we got everything
now i haven't watched sports in years
and i'm excited about them and yeah i
still draft king it i love little
draftkings i had a great time with
draftkings this weekend but now i'm just
watching college basketball just to i
haven't watched college basketball since
[__] michael jordan [__] played so
that just goes to show you how busy i've
been [__] i love you at all my
heart stay black have a great week
and we'll get this all fixed up and i'll
be back 100
tip top [__] magoo
monday the 10th it's my daughter's
birthday this weekend i'm excited about
that i can't even have a party because
everybody's getting [__] coping can
you believe this [__] that means if i
was 14 i couldn't even swap spit with a
girl suck at titties this week because
you might get [__] covered not the
deal anyway we're just having six little
girls sleeping over
i love you [__] are all my
heart laughing gas is in full effect
still getting us [__] high show me
the back then
boom there you go
is it upside down though ah tremendous
smells like [__] some guy crossing
the board his feet that's how good that
[__] smells where's the kids at the
border they're probably [__] 20 by
now they're probably driving up the
[__] coast by now they don't talk
about the kids on the border no more
what happened if you know where they are
hit me up hey
what happened to the black kid that had
flies on them same thing i want to know
what happened to the black kid with the
flies and i want to know what happened
to the kids in the border nobody's
talking about them no more there was a
thousand of them in cages and now they
disappeared i don't know i seen a little
mexican kid in freehold last week i was
going to ask him he had one of those 10
[__] blankets hot and [__]
i love you [__] stay black have
a great week and uncle joey still has it
somewhere in there i love you
[__] all right you bad
[__] i want to thank you guys
for putting up with this here beating on
a beautiful [__] wednesday
you know what man
you have good days and you have bad days
i've been struggling a little lately and
uh i'm sorry about it but we're making a
[__] comeback but anyway
from the heart of new jersey the joint
is brought to you by draftkings listen
it's the final week of pro football
before the playoffs we got a couple bowl
games left we got nba basketball you got
college basketball you got so much to
make money on uncle joey's coming at you
with a great deal today well draftkings
is here for you
bet five hours on any football team to
win that game
and if you win
you win 200 in free bets where you gonna
get that at some [__] jamok sports
book no no no there's nothing like
draftkings
draftkings is tremendous basketball
college i mean
casinos baccarat they got everything
they got a draftkings dallasy fantasy
football contest i don't know if ben
needs your stuff
how about fantasy get a free shot at
winning millions of dollars in total
prizes with your first deposit on
draftkings
everyone can play for huge cash prizes
with draftkings now if it's not
available like i said if you don't want
to play the
fantasy you got the sports book and you
got a casino with a live
[__] guy there playing blackjack with
you draftkings has put together a
tremendous virtual casino and guess what
nobody breathes on you and you can't get
covered in that but hey it starts with
you download the draftking sportsbook
app
press code joey and let's win some money
let's make 2020 youtube let's start off
with a [__] bang so all you gotta do
is use promo code joey this week at
draftking sportsbook must be 21 older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only
new customers only minimum final deposit
one dollar wager required
one per customer please restrictions do
apply see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details now if you've got a gaming
problem
call 1-800 gamble but if not head over
to the draftking sportsbook app and
let's win some money
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion
in the world the cbd cbd lion is the
king listen to me there's a lot of
people out there pushing through gazi
products i've been with cbd lion for
years now
they've been with me they helped me i
love all their products from the
tincture to the cream to the unscented
cream to the capsules to the back balls
to the kinesiology tape listen they do
it all at cbd line but look let's do
this just go to cbd line read all the
third-party lab results
see what works for you maybe they could
push you in the right direction for the
helm whatever helmet you may have press
and co joey and get 10 off delivered to
your crib it's that easy
i love cbd lion and so will you
and the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com one of my favorites and best
sponsor i'll tell you why because
they're valuable if you got a small
business
there's nothing more valuable than your
time
stamps.com makes it easy to mail
and ship right from your home it's that
easy stop wasting trips on
stop wasting time on trips to the post
office you can save time and money and
energy with stamps.com send letters
packages
for less with discounted rates from usps
ups and more listen man my wife has been
using uh stamps.com i watch it it's nice
and easy just schedule a pickup and the
mailman comes to your house and gets
everything all you need is a computer
and a standard printer no special
supplies or equipment with the minutes
you're up and running
printing postage for any letter
any package anywhere
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup no traffic no lines nobody
breathing on your neck none of that
stuff all you need to do there's no risk
save time and money with stamps.com what
i'm going to do is use promo code joey
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in joey that's stamps.com
promo code joey never go to the post
office again with stamps.com i want to
thank stamps.com
i want to thank draftkings and i want to
thank cbd lion
for making it happen this week but most
importantly i want to thank you guys
thank you have a great week and i'll see
you [__] monday morning tip top
magoo
[Music]
so
you